ما الفرق الذي قد يحدثه في الميدان تزويد
واشنطن لكياف بمنظومه الدفاع الجوي
فيتريوت
ثلاثه منظومه الدفاع جوي ارض جو تحمل
القذفه منها 16 صاروخا تضاف لها مركبه
الرادار وغرفه التحكم يصل مدى الصاروخ الى
نحو 70 كيلو مترا بارتفاع اقصى اربعه
وعشرون مترا يقوم نظام الرادار الارضي
الخاص بالمنظومه بكشف الهدف وتتبعه في
دائره قطرها 80 كم يطلق صاروخ بيت نحو
الهدف لتفجيره قبل وصوله الى وجهته فصاروخ
مجهز بنظام توجيه للمصاري وتصحيحه وهو
قادر على اعتراض وتفجير الصواريخ
البالستيه وصواريخ كروز وبعض انواع
الطائرات توجد منظومه التي تعمل وفق
المسؤولين الامريكيين على تامين المجال
الجويه في اوروبا الشرقيه ومنها رومانيا
وبولندا كما توجد المنظومه في دول اوروبيه
اخرى كالمانيا وهولندا واسبانيا وسائل
اعلام امريكي ذكرت اخيرا قد تصل الى
اوكرانيا في وقت قريب لكن وضعها في
المعركه قد يحتاج الى وقت اطول نظرا
للحاجه الى تدريب الاوكرانيين على
استخدامها الامر الذي قد يستغرق من وجهه
نظرهم اشهرا بكاملها